we begin this morning with passage of
the biggest change to the nation's tax
code in decades appears to be all but
certain after weeks of wavering
prospects Republicans wavering prospects
lawmakers appear to have enough votes to
pass the sweeping measure affecting
every taxpayer and business in the u.s.
passage would give President Trump his
first major legislative victory but the
bill is projected to add almost one and
a half trillion dollars to the budget
deficit over the coming decade once hold
out senators Marco Rubio and bob corker
have now both agreed to support the
final version of the bill putting it on
track for a vote in the days ahead
Errol Barnett is on Capitol Hill with
the latest arrow good morning good
morning
you're right now that key Republican
hold outs have signed on GOP leaders are
on track to pass this bill as early as
next week
but there is quite a lot of fine print
so lawmakers will likely spend the
weekend going through the bills more
than 500 pages president Trump is
bullish on getting a tax cut bill on his
desk by Christmas
the final Republican plan retains seven
personal tax brackets with rates
dropping for almost everyone a family
earning 75 thousand dollars a year for
example would see its marginal rate drop
from 15 to 12% everyone's lives will be
better off under tax reform because of
the tax relief families get Republican
leaders made a last-minute change Friday
boosting the refundable portion of the
child tax credit to $1,400 that means
the low income parents pocket that money
even if they don't owe taxes this is
good for working families that earn back
the vote of Florida's Marco Rubio and
fellow holdout bob Corker the Tennessee
senator set aside his concerns about the
deficit and called this bill a
once-in-a-generation opportunity to make
us businesses more productive and
competitive it's a monumental con job
the public knows it's awful Democrats
call the bill a sham and
say this is a giveaway to big businesses
American people buy substantial numbers
believe this bill is not good for them
the bill slashes the corporate tax rate
permanently from 35 to 21 percent while
most of the personal tax cuts expire in
2025 are you there is a catch for
Republicans arizona's john mccain and
Mississippi's fat cochran miss votes all
week due to health issues lawmakers are
hopeful for their return i think john
mccain will be here now the White House
is keenly aware of the slim Republican
majority here and the importance of this
bill to president Trump's domestic
agenda so it is delaying a scheduled
trip to the Middle East next week by
Vice President Mike Pence just in case
his tie-breaking vote is needed Anthony
Errol Barnett on Capitol Hill thanks
Harold